[Music]
the movie clash of the titans showed us
how awesome the monsters of greek
mythology could be
unlike the ones from percy jackson and
the olympians these creatures were
deadlier and had no mercy
their design and cgi portrayals were
also top
notch embarrassing the rest of the
competition the franchise now spans
three movies a video game and many
comics but in this video we shall only
focus on the ones from the movies and
games
if there are some who are confused about
the fact that i said three movies
then i should tell you that there was a
movie created in 1981 called clash of
the titans
and the 2010 movie was just its remake
now that we have that cleared up
let's get to the 15 monsters and
creatures of clash of the titans
franchise
number 15 the stygian witches in greek
mythology the stygian witches are three
old women that know almost everything
about the future
they are blind but they could see
through a shared mystical eye
which they put near their ocular holes
they are seen in a 2010 remake in
another fashion style
looking more like mummies than humans
they have a human body
but with the faces that possess no
distinguishable features
other than their mouths they are draped
in very old clothing and are hunched in
posture
but are very agile and powerful with the
only weakness is their eye that they
possess
and when standing straight they are six
feet tall
number 14 the furies the furies in the
movie as well as in greek mythology were
flying minions of hades
they were seen as having bat like wings
but in the game they were seen with
feathers
in a 2010 movie remake they take the
shape of medium-sized black skin
humanoid bats
they first appeared when they burst out
of the water and start attacking the
soldiers who were pushing
the giant statue of zeus they then
combined into a massive sphere
and destroyed spirus's fishing ship
later more of these bat-like theories
begin to follow
and attack perseus and the pegasus in
order to steal medusa's head
although powerful they are easily killed
with a single sword swipe
that could slice off their wings and
also they were of human size
number 13 the minotaur this creature is
a ferocious combination of man and bees
in the midst a long time ago poseidon
gifted king minors of crete with a snow
white bull but when miners failed to
sacrifice it as a sign of respect to the
god
poseidon caused the king's wife to fall
in love
with the alluring creature and their
spawn took shape as a powerful
bullheaded barbarian
this was the minotaur it had red glowing
eyes and thick coarse hair that covered
its body
the minotaur also had grey skin and of
course two large horns
the minotaur can influence on its
victims for them to see images and hear
voices of their loved ones inside the
labyrinth
it was the size of a human but had
superhuman strength
number 12 the jinn the jinn were
portrayed as ancient sorcerers who lived
in the desert
they replaced their organs and limbs
with dark magic and ash
and were the only ones who could tame
the giant scorpions
they are impervious to the stare of the
gorgons that turn people to stone
most likely because their lack of flesh
and blood as they are in essence nothing
more than spirits inhabiting a false
body
overall they played a big role in the
movie first saving perseus and the
survivors
of the god from the wrath of the
scorpions and then later weakening
medusa
they also helped quicken their journey
by allowing them to travel on the giant
scorpions
these gins were taller than most humans
at around 7 feet in height
number 11 the pegasus the pegasus in
greek mythology was the son of poseidon
and medusa
he was born from his mother's neck after
percy slayed her
pegasus appears both in the 1981 film
and also in the 2010 remake just before
medusa's death
not following the original myth although
the original color of pegasus was white
as in the greek mythology he is seen as
black in a 2010 movie remake
in the original myths pegasus and
belaforon fought against the chimera
and was not connected with purses in any
way the creature is a dashing
black horse that possesses two gigantic
eagle-like wings
and its size is often portrayed as the
size of a doll stallion
more than seven feet tall at the head
number 10
charon the birdman or also known as
charon
in greek mythology is the fairy man of
hades who carries souls across the river
sticks to erebus
or the underworld in a 1981 and a 2010
film
the death boat takes purses along with
three men to medusa's lair
in which the hero takes off her head in
order to defeat the kraken
a coin to pay the charon for passage it
was sometimes placed
in or on the mouth of a dead person but
in the 2010 remake the head man of the
gin
throws the coin into the water and then
he appears
sharon in the 2010 movie is seen as an
integral part of the boat
and he was like a woody skeleton mummy
figure that was anywhere between eight
to nine
feet tall number nine the makhai
the makai in greek mythology are the
gods or spirits of battle and combat
the makai skin has a charred and
corroded look and their faces look
slightly deformed there are lines of
lava on the makai's skin
both of the heads wear a helmet but the
head on the right wears a helmet with a
plume
and is less muscular than the left head
the makai's skin seems to be made of
volcanic rock
they have two upper bodies attached by
the backs with two heads
the makai's weapons of choice are four
short blade swords
two in each hand which they use by
spinning and changing the side as they
are facing constantly in battle these
battle spirits of the titans are eight
to nine feet tall
number eight the chimera the chimera is
an amalgamation of multiple creatures
it has two heads a pair of colossal
wings and a tail equipped with a
serpent's head
it is known to rely on teamwork between
its two heads
as one of the heads throws the fuel and
the other one
ignites and generates a super heated
breath which ignites in midair
in the wrath of the titans the chimera
is among the plethora of creatures
unleashed by hades into earth
a horde of chimeras is unleashed near
percy's village and at least one of them
targets percy's village
and reeks have a killing and burning
whoever comes on its way
this beast was around 20 to 30 feet long
and had a long tail with a snake's head
at the tip
number 7 medusa medusa in greek
mythology was a woman cursed with those
glare that had a power to transform men
into stone statues
but in the movie she and her sisters
were once beautiful maidens
full of promise and hope medusa was the
goddess athena's prized priestess until
medusa was raped by the sea god poseidon
medusa and her two sisters were then
turned into the gorgons by athena
and she was banished from the world of
man despite her innocence in the whole
ordeal
in a 2010 movie medusa had the body of a
woman
and a beautiful face with snakes as
dreadlocks aside from this her lower
body
was that of a gigantic serpent easily
over 40 feet long
number six the skeleton king the
skeleton king is a colossal monster
guarding the gates of medusa's lair
the skeleton king is able to release
massive beams of unknown purple energy
from his mouth
this creature is only seen in clash of
the titans the video game
which is a hack and slash action
adventure game based on the 2010 film
clash of the titans
the skeleton king was seen as a huge
monster over 30 feet tall
and his body was made up of giant bones
that protrude outwards
and inwards and most suddenly in all
directions
his head was that of a big humanoid
having three conjoined eyes that glowed
blue in color
its mouth was lined with sharp teeth and
had two collarbones stacked up against
its face like a stacks antlers
number five the cyclops in these foul
fearsome creatures called cyclops are a
breed of cannibal giants endowed with
brute strength
and a single eye in the middle of their
foreheads so powerful are these
primitive monsters at uranus
imprisoned them in an underworld abyss
where they were guarded by a dragon
and so goes the myth about them in the
movie there are three main cyclops in
the round of titans
and they are 30 feet tall when the
navigator led perseus andromeda and the
soldiers to a hidden island
by using poseidon's trident at their
arrival they encountered traps laid by
the cyclops which led to a prolonged
battle
that ended in the cyclops helping the
protagonists towards
reaching the layer of the god hephaestus
number four scorpions these gigantic
scorpions have no real root in greek or
arabic mythology and were most probably
original concept of the movie
and they were nonetheless amazing they
differ from both movie versions
as they differ in proportion as the
scorpions of the 1981 film were
at most the size of a human in height in
a 2010 remake we see a bigger type of
scorpion
with most of them over twice or twice
the size of a human
and move much faster in a 1981 film
perseus along with his men fought
against three scorpions that attacked
them
while they were asleep in the 2010
remake they fight a total of six
with the biggest one appearing at the
end and is easily over 50 to 60 feet
long
and more than 15 feet tall number three
the sand worm
the next monster is called the sand worm
and it is a colossal creature appearing
in clash of the titans the video game
it appeared at quest 29 into the fire as
the final part of the sequence in a boss
battle
although only half of its body is seen
out of the ground
in the most part of the battle we don't
know if it had multiple heads or
if the main one was huge and a few
smaller ones kept on resurfacing in the
battle
it had spikes on its skin that we know
that was heavily segmented
and these spikes were mainly for
movement on the ground its mouth was
lined with multiple jaws
and it can spew out greenish acidic spit
as ranged weapons
we can only assume that its total length
to be over 100 feet long
number two the kraken on contrary to
popular belief the kraken was in fact a
mythological creature
and sea monster of scandinavian origin
and not of greek myths
it is a monster of tremendous size of
strength said to exist
of the course of norway and greenland
but in the movie the kraken appears
as an adversary of perseus the movie
narrator explained that hades created it
to slay the titans
unlike the squid portrayals of earlier
movies this kraken had tentacles
but with an upper body of a humanoid
appearance that had muscular arms
and crap like legs the kraken was
released onto argos to destroy it but
purchase slated
with medusa's head that turned it into
stone
this kraken was titanic in size easily
over 400 feet tall
number one cronus this monster is the
king of the titans
and the father of the gods in wrath of
the titans
krona's physical form is composed of
lava and molten rock with lines of lava
surrounding his body
mouth and eyes which would suggest that
the inside part of his body is also
completely composed of volcanic lava
he is capable of projecting massive
waves of lava from his arms which would
constitute his ranged attack
it is also seen that cronus can spawn
hordes of makai
from his very own flesh and also from
tartarus
both the makai and the chimeras are seen
to be affiliated to kronos
rather than hades in the movie this
monster is
truly a titan dwarfing the kraken and it
was four times its height
at more than sixteen hundred feet tall
and so with that we come to the end of
the list of the creatures and monsters
of the clash of the titans movie
franchise
and also the games do hit the subscribe
button for more videos like these